time here in nevada the numbers as we
just saw there show biden with a very
slim
lead and orco mana joins us now live
near the las vegas strip with a bit more
on when we'll see more of those numbers
and who those numbers may
favor all about tomorrow morning orco
yeah brian and denise the nevada
secretary of state's office wanted to
release
more results today because of the
interest across the country
that didn't happen the next number
should be available tomorrow morning
but final results could be days away
all eyes are on nevada the state's six
electoral votes gaining increasing
importance in the race to 270 between
president donald trump and former vice
president joe biden
8 000 votes separate the two candidates
but hundreds of thousands of votes have
not been counted yet so the big question
what's taking so long
right now we're just waiting on the
remaining
mail ballots deputy secretary of state
for elections wayne thorley saying
there's a longer timeline for counting
mail ballots based on nevada law
those ballots can be counted up to a
week after the election
as long as they're postmarked by
election day
so there are ballots in the mail stream
that are still working their way through
that we will end up counting
voters can also cure the signature on
their ballot until the end of next week
we are working feverishly to get all of
that
counted clark county planning to release
new results daily starting thursday
registrar of voters joe gloria
announcing all early and all election
day votes have been counted and there's
more than just mail ballots left to go
provisional ballots electronic ballots
that were sent to overseas voters
electronic ballots that were processed
for disabled voters
and also some special ballots for new
residents
gloria says his office is able to
process up to 70 thousand ballots a day
but it's hard to say how many ballots
are left to count because all nevada
voters were sent a mail ballot state
officials urging nevadans to let the
process play out so be patient
the all the ballots aren't going to be
counted today they're not going to all
be counted tomorrow
now the nevada secretary of state's
office says it'll be announcing
unofficial election results daily
starting at 9 00 a.m tomorrow
and we're also told that those results
will be loaded
county by county so don't expect to see
all of them on the website right away
we also want to mention that maitland
votes tend to lean
democratic so that's something to keep
in mind as we start seeing those numbers
tomorrow
reporting live tonight near the las
vegas strip orca mana 8 news now